sans plus tarder en fait nous allons
aborder notre premier thème de la soirée
c'est le smic outre mer et je vais
laisser la parole à max dubois président
de air et d'hommes merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup américain derrière ce que nous
ont fait une étude une étude importante
et que tout ce que nous avons projeté
ici que je n'ai pas nécessairement
commenté était la disposition de tous
les observateurs on a un ça tangue le
constat qu on a fait il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté très rapidement et on a quatre
ans passant qui de gentils mais sous le
seuil de pauvreté l'hexagone remonte à
52 % en guyane 34 guadeloupe à peu près
la même chose en martinique 42% la
réunion les 77 points sa meilleure ça ça
parle la sismique de rattrapage pourquoi
parce que on peut revenir sur ce qu'elle
demande est là aucun des deux candidats
l'élection présidentielle envisage de
supprimer les surrémunérations alors ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si aucun
candidat nous dit qu'il faut enlever les
surrémunérations je vous rassure gérer
des monnaies plutôt d'accord il faut pas
les oublier ça veut dire que hilda coup
de surrémunération et ça veut dire que
le salaire sur rémunérés c'est en
réalité la base du salaire et que les
autres sont sous la mairie c'est ça que
ça veut dire on a une crise dans les
territoires d'outre-mer elle naît
d'abord sur les inégalités et si on
règle pas les preuves des inégalités
deuxième problème c'est qu'il faut faire
une différence entre de gens qui
travaillent des gens qui travaillent pas
depuis quand je parais des décennies et
des décennies l'état fait du transfert
social on a deux mécaniques qui
fonctionne un gros l'économie de rente
continue à fonctionner très bien donc
les politiques publiques continuent
d'envoyer des sous pour rafa c'est
quelqu'un que je connais bien un peu nom
de dan tout de même et de l'autre côté
on nous voit des transferts sociaux
quand les gens sont pas contents monde
ça ça ne peut pas durer et il faut
recréer également une envie de
travailler pour ça il faut payer les
gens d'une manière convenable et avec
1270 euros par mois de salaire pour un
smic on n'y arrive pas donc voilà donc
10 est ce que c'est possible est ce que
c'est possible d'augmenter le salaire
leva de fabriquer un smic inquiète à
smic donc de plus 20% par rapport au
smig qui existent en france hexagonale
combien ça coûte et qui paye donc le qui
paye clairement c'est l'état les
entreprises n'ont absolument pas les
moyens aujourd'hui de mettre un centime
de plus ça c'est très clair mais par
contre combien ça coûte à l'état est-ce
que c'est aussi puis quand on dit le
smic il faut penser à la totalité des
salaires dans les territoires
d'outre-mer s'est on peut pas dire on
augmente le smic de ma portion qui les
autres qui sont juste après le smic on
ne peut pas donc nous avons changé les
donnes commandé une étude on a commandé
l'étude du sud riquet taco dibbits têtu
venir rejoindre olivier donc olivier
sudrie et maître de conférence à paris
ça qu il est en même temps le patron
d'un cabinet très connu qui s'appelle
cabinet de m qui fait beaucoup de
simulations économiques dans les
territoires d'outre-mer et depuis trente
ans donc olivier tu connais parfaitement
ses dossiers donc quand je t'ai
rencontré jeudi bon je vais augmenter
les salaires de 1% roule
donc on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on va
ramasser qu'est ce qu'on va prendre et
on s'est mis a beaucoup travaillé sur le
sujet et je te passe la parole olivier
et tu vas nous expliquer combien ça
coûte habitat voilà à toi l'idée si on
augmente le smic de 20% que se
passe-t-il dans l'ensemble des économies
ultramarines dans l'ensemble des ddd
département plutôt d'outre-mer comment
répondre à cette question quand ils se
passaient alors il ya plusieurs
solutions la boule de cristal le marc de
café ou les entrailles de pouvait c'est
chez nous on utilise plutôt des modèles
on amorcé à la demande de deux heures et
dames en fait sur le point de départ
c'est très simple et si on augmentait de
20 % c'est pas rien est ce que tout le
monde va bénéficier de ces 20% voilà non
pas tout à fait et max l'évoquait quand
on est payé au smic ou jusqu'à 1,3 smic
oui là dans ces cas là on est majorée de
20% et puis on le voit ici sur ce schéma
que je vais pas commenter un bien
évidemment quand on son salaire est
supérieur à 1,3 smic et bien en fait la
prime
de la sueur majoration du smic va aller
decrescendo et jusqu'à 2,5 smic à partir
duquel il n'y a plus de n'y a plus de
prix max le rappelait il ya un instant
qui va payer c'est une chose vraiment
très importante et on est tous tombés
d'accord effectivement c'est l'état
parce que nous connaissons bien le tissu
entrepreneurial un des départements
d'outre-mer nous connaissons aussi les
difficultés d'une très grande majorité
d'entreprises et surtout net de tout
prélèvement obligatoire on va pas donner
dans une main ce qu'on va reprendre de
l'autre on est tous d'accord
80% des salariés dans l'ensemble donc
des départements d'outre-mer y compris
mayotte serait bénéficiaire de cette
mesure 80% des salariés c'est en fait un
petit peu plus mon art on dit plutôt à
la baisse deux cent cinquante mille
salariés bénéficiaires de cette mesure
c'est directement du pouvoir d'achat en
plus en moyenne pour les quatre
géographie ça fait à peu près 160 euros
par mois mais pour les je dirais les
salariés les plus modestes ceux qui sont
entre le smic est donc 1,3 smic ça leur
fait 2 120 euros par mois c'est pas
ridicule l'armoise n'est pas négligeable
470 millions d'euros par an bien
évidemment eh bien ça représente
simplement 2 3% 1 2 ce qu'on appelle
dans notre jargon l'effort budgétaire de
l'état dans les départements d'outre-mer
valois savait pas si lourde que ça 2,3
pour cent et puis un max l'évoquait non
à propos de la sur rémunération alors
cette fois ci des fonctions publiques
qu'elles soient et à territoriale ou
hospitalière outre-mer on a essayé de
regarder est ce que par rapport à ces
sur rémunérations qui sont de l'ordre de
mémoire à peu près de 950 millions
d'euros pour la fonction publique d'état
bah ça représente la moitié si il
s'échappait permettre de dévier donc là
tu viens de parler du petit milliard
d'euros que coûte la surrémunération
pour la surrémunération des
fonctionnaires de l'état mais quand on
regarde aussi la fonction publique
territoriale
c'est un peu plus de 400 millions
d'euros ça veut dire que la seule
fonction publique territoriale pas un
sur immigration ce que nous demandons
pour totalité des salariés qui sont un
domaine du privé c'est bien ça
exactement mais tout à fait absolument
et c'est cette consommation qui va
impulser qui va redonner du tonus à nos
économies qui en manquent
malheureusement beaucoup en ce moment
mais par des effets aussi de boules de
neige la consommation d un c'est la
production aussi local la production
locale c'est aussi des revenus
supplémentaires c'est de nouveau de la
consommation et quand on fait les
comptes jusqu'au bout eh bien on sais tu
ce supplément ici injecté aux alentours
donc des 470 millions d'euros se traduit
par 720 millions d'euros de consommation
dans les départements d'outre-mer quand
on sait que la consommation des ménages
c'est le moteur de la croissance à court
terme là on a appuyé sur le champignon
et bien évidemment les entreprises vont
être largement aussi bénéficiaires de la
mesure puisque une grande partie de
notre consommation s'adresse aux
entreprises locales ses 480 millions de
valeur ajoutée c'est 1,2 pour cent du
total de la valeur ajoutée certains
c'est une croissance de 1,2 pour cent
c'est quand on cherche de la croissance
est bien là on la trouve c'est très
clair très très con il y a augmentation
de la consommation il y à augmentation
de l'activité et forcément il y à aussi
soutien de l'emploi il y à peu près 4000
emplois qui sont concernés
c'est à dire créer ou conforter c'est à
peu près 1% de l'emploi marche et puis
dernier élément et j'arrêterai là
rassurez-vous sur le sol de ces aspects
évaluation max évoquaient eux justice
passe et mon expérience est une plaie de
l'outre-mer 1 c'est sur les inégalités
qui sont non seulement socialement
injuste mais aussi qu'ils sont
économiquement inefficace c'est que
quand on est inégalitaire aussi on a la
moindre croissance tout simplement quand
les revenus vont dans des poches qui
sont déjà remplies qui ne consomment pas
beaucoup parce que dans certain
catégorie sociale en est à satiété et
bien forcément cet argent il n'est pas
réinjecté alors que ici va l'être et
bien cette mesure puisqu'elle va
permettre justement aux salariés les
plus modestes d'avoir de bénéficier ce
sont les plus modestes qui auront les
220 c'est ado rouvert les d1 d2 d3 d4 d5
et bien ça va réduire ces inégalités et
salé réduit pas du tout dans l'épaisseur
du trait c'est une notion qui va réduire
on a toutes mesures et le plus finement
possible 15% de réduction des inégalités
je ne connais pas de mesures qui
qu'ils soient dans cet ordre de grandeur
la ce qu'on pouvait dire de alors si
chéri cher olivier qu'est ce qu'on va
nous raconter dans cette affaire là on
va nous dire que évidemment les mêmes
vont en profiter et qui va y avoir une
inflation déjà on nous dit ça on va nous
dire mais si vous donner plus de pouvoir
d'achat ce qui aujourd'hui sont déjà les
jeux les appels mais sarko ne regarde
que moi les prédateurs économiques bien
connus vont se jeter sur ce nouveau
gâteau et au fond tout ce que nous
sommes en train d'imaginer risque de
passer par le fond c'est à dire dans le
fond des poches de ceux qui sont déjà là
alors qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire
olivier des moyens à mettre en oeuvre
pour garder ce
cet argent là on pouvoir d'achat et
deuxième question olivier on nous sommes
dans une inflation on voit aujourd'hui
le coût des transports qui a fortement
augmenté on se dit aussi nous avons
aujourd'hui une augmentation très
importante des transports dans
lesquelles il ya encore quasiment un
monopole cma-cgm aujourd'hui qui avait
augmenté ses prix et aujourd'hui
1,8
fin xviii pendant 18 milliard d'euros 18
milliards d'euros de bénéfices par an en
ce moment en ce moment 18 milliards
d'euros donc et pour autant les boîtes
sont plus en plus cher donc que quand le
transport augmente ça veut dire que et
bien tout comme monte à la consommation
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
empêcher les gens qui sont en situation
de monopole de dire ouh là là ils vont
augmenter de 20% mais ça ça va rentrer
dans ma poche et ils font que notre
mesure et bien il ne sert plus à rien
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire deux choses
la première concernant l'inflation
effectivement actuellement nous sommes
dans un choc inflationniste
qui quittent qui touche l'ensemble des
d'aider des pays développés donc ça ce
choc gérer ça rend encore plus
nécessaire peut-être ce type de mesure
parce que il va ce choc on le sert il
frappe en premier lieu les familles les
plus modestes qui ont déjà du mal à
finir les fins de mois et donc en fait
quand les prix augmentent et les
augmente encore plus un pour les foyers
modestes que pour les plus riches qui
ont quand même un matelas d'épargné qui
peuvent faire face éventuellement un
show prix plus facilement alors ce
serait très compliqué ces mots c'est une
question mais c'est une colle il faut
être honnête nous sommes dans un système
d'économie libérale nous n'en prendrons
pas les prix dont vous pourrez pas dire
voilà on va majorer le smic outre mer il
va bloquer les prix outre mer partant de
ce que l'on peut faire c'est une giresse
est une information
on a la chance outre-mer d'avoir des
observatoires des prix des marges et des
revenus et je crois que ces
observatoires ont un rôle tout à fait
important à jouer c'est pas qu'ils vont
bloquer l'inflation mais c'est eux qui
vont siffler peut-être la fin de la
partie en sans dénoncer mais
enregistrait en communiquant sud là
dessus il faut que peut-être que
l'observatoire qui aurait peut-être
cette charge de mesurer les prix à
l'importation et qui sont là c'est une
inflation mondiale importé vis-à-vis
laquelle on ne peut rien faire et puis
de les mettre ensuite en comparaison
avec les prix intérieurs et si on voit
des dérapages là il ya peut-être
effectivement des explications à
demander un certain nombre d'opérateurs
il faut jouer groupés dans ces cas là
c'est si on ne joue pas groupe et aucun
des avantages que vous ai présenté très
rapidement nous les aurons il fait donc
une politique publique c'est donc une
volonté politique qui peut régler en
très grande partie en période de pneus
lectorale nous espérons que cette mesure
sera reprise au bond candidats alors
merci max et surtout pour votre
intervention donc pour rappel olivier
sudrie qui est maître de conférences à
l'université paris saclay mais aussi
économistes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]